one of the many things that comes to
mind that Ben Franklin is incredible
time management
um
is there something you could say about
Ben Franklin and about Steve Jobs I
think interesting with Elon is that he
as you write uh run six companies seven
depends how you count star link is its
own thing I don't know
um
what can you say about these people in
terms of time management well musk is
in a league of his own and the way he
does it first of all
yeah Steve Jobs had to run Pixar and
Apple for a while but musk every couple
of hours is switching his mindset from
how to implant the neural link chip and
what will the robot that implants it in
the brain look like and how fast can we
make it move
and then the heat shield on the Raptor
or switching to human imitation machine
learning full self drive on the night
that the Twitter board
uh agreed to the deal
this is huge around the world I'm sure
you remember like musk buys Twitter it
wouldn't win the deal closed it was when
the Twitter accepted his offer and I
thought okay
but then he went to Boca Chica to South
Texas
and spent time
fixating on if I remember correctly a
valve in the Raptor engine that had a
methane leak issue
and what were the possible ways to fix
it
and all the engineers in that room
I assume are thinking about this guy
just bought Twitter should we say
something and he's like and then he goes
with Kimball to a roadside joint
uh in Brownsville and just sits in the
front and listens to music with nobody
noticing really him being there
one of the things that one of his
strengths and sort of weaknesses in a
way
is in a given day
he'll Focus serially sequentially on
many different things he will worry
about
uh uploading video onto x.com or the
payment system and then immediately
switch over to some issue with the FAA
giving a permit for Starship or with how
to deal with starlink and the CIA
and when he's focused on any of these
things
you cannot distract him it's not like
he's also thinking about I'm dealing
with starlink but I've got to also worry
about the Tesla decision on the new 25
000 car
now he'll in between these sessions
process information then let off steam
and for better or worse he lets off
steam by
either playing a friend in politopia or
fire off some tweets which is often not
a healthy thing but it's a release for
him
and he doesn't I once said he was a
great multitasker and that was a mistake
people corrected me he's a Serial Tasker
which means focus is intensely on a task
for an hour
almost has a what do they call it at
restaurants where they give you a
palette cleanser yeah he does some
palette cleanser with polytopia yeah and
then focuses on the next task I mean is
there some wisdom about time management
that you can draw from that there are
some things that these people do and you
say okay I can be that way I can be more
Curious I can question every Rule and
regulation
I I just don't think anybody
to try to emulate musk time management
style because it takes a certain set of
teams you know how to deal with
everything else other than the thing
he's focusing on and a certain
mind that can shift just like his moods
can shift uh you and I go through
Transitions and also if I'm thinking
about what I'm going to say on this
podcast I'm also thinking about the
email my daughter just sent about a
house that she's looking you know and
I'm
I'm multitasking he doesn't actually do
that he single tasks sequentially with a
focus that's hardcore I don't know I
think there's wisdom to draw from that
to like first of all he makes me Ben
Franklin makes me feel that way that
there's a lot of hours in the day
there's a lot of minutes in the day like
there's no excuse not to get a lot done
and that requires just an extreme Focus
extreme focusing like an urgency I think
the fierce
urgency
that
drives him is important
and it's sometimes gend up
like I say the fierce urgency of getting
to Mars and on a Friday night at the
launch pad in Boca Chica at 10 pm there
are only a few people working because
it's a Friday night they're not supposed
to launch for another eight months
and he orders The Surge he says I want
200 people here by tomorrow working on
this pad we have to have a fierce sense
of urgency or we will never get to Mars
that sense of urgency you know
is also a vibrancy
that's like really taking on life fully
I mean that to me this the lesson is
like
even the mundane can be full of this
just richness and like you just have to
really uh take it in intensely it's like
the switching
enables that kind of intensity because
most of us can't hold that intense than
any one tasks for a prolonged period of
time maybe that's also a lesson
right and I guess it goes back to also
know who you are meaning there are
people who
can focus intensely and there are people
who can see patterns across many things
look Leonardo da Vinci
he was not all that focused he was
easily distracted it's why he has more
unfinished paintings and finished
paintings in his Canon yeah
um but his ability to
see patterns across nature and to in
some ways
process procrastinate be distracted
that helped him some
but musk is in not that way and there
every few months as a new surge you
don't know where it'll be but you'll be
on solar roofs and all of a sudden we'll
have a surge and there has to be you
know 100 solar roofs built or this has
to be done by tomorrow or make a
Starship dome by Dawn and Surge and do
it
um and there are people who are built
that way it is inspiring
but also let's appreciate you know that
there are people who can be really good
uh
but uh also can savor
the success Savor the moment Savor the
quiet sometimes
must big failing is he can't save her
the moment or success and that's the
flip side of Hardcore intensity